January 1st [__] wash your [__]
clean your toes it's a whole new year
with no restriction you understand me
we're going deep into the murky waters
tonight [__] so if you would
think another night to lose your mind so
that is it
if you've got some leftover ecstasy
[__] heroin or whatever the [__] you
got the house tonight sit grandma's
cancer pills I don't give a [__] jack
- a beautiful day to be alive you made
it 2018 man when you think about 2018
you'd say I'll never be around for 2018
you were wrong [__] you're here
you're about to get high with uncle Joey
[Music]
perfect yeah
[Laughter]
you bad [__] there that clouded
dead please still got [__] beside this
in the salon what do you got bronchitis
beside this this poor kid that bong hit
took him to the deepest channels of his
lung in the stand me that was the night
we smoked the mushrooms we took him down
the mushroom game of bronchitis and [__]
[Laughter]
the meal is back [__] you do a hit of
this you know they want you to do a full
shot you do a hit from this meal that's
the flu shot oh [__] it's 2018
[__] wash your [__] cut your
toenails it's over get that fungi toll
and scrub it down i buffed out my
toenail on the 30th tremendous I had
like three grams of toenail dust just
floating all over the place either white
goggles with everything looking good
with the Johnny moon Tobby hairdo a
hundred and forty fifth check it out
[__] head - of death young Sam don't
worry about the back all right wants you
the back cause you want to see my ass
you you're the same type of hormone I
got grab that [__] dude's dick what's
his name [__] the black dude Macumba
anyway we're here come seconds July
January first you made it another year
whatever happened last you happen last
year if somebody took that dick out made
you something and you sucked it it's in
the past there's nothing you can do
about it
it's 2018 [__] whatever you
could do you got to do now you follow me
this is the year before the Korean
strikes because you don't want no
[__] misunderstanding it's a
beautiful week to be alive we got
tonight we got Wednesday sadly what the
I south is sold out [__] Sunday we're
back Tuesday we're back we got podcast
from [__] debt coming for you but who
gives a [__] all were worried about is
tec-9 [__] it's a fool
I got the police synchronicity 1983 one
of the greatest albums ever to be put on
the vinyl then that [__] egotistical
[__] with the ukulele sting how to
break them up [__] him
and the horsey roll up on now right now
we're gonna go deep tonight me and Lee
Lee we're gonna start the new year at
the full moon out of respect we're gonna
split five of these we haven't done this
and the stars are here too
you follow me wait [__] around
tonight so you gotta go to work listen
turn off the periscope right now this
it's gonna get ugly in this [__]
tonight then we're switching over to
youtube.com slash c / joey dis did you
know what that's the place to be but you
can't walk on one leg and I'm saying joy
which with the chitchat let's park the
[__] number let's [__] [__] that
number you know saying there's a little
black and the Sun today
oh yes cleaning out the mule maintenance
is important when you have a bung
understanding if you're not gonna
maintain the bong it's gonna [__]
throw up on you I smelled like dick and
then what do you got you got nothing you
might as well be in [__] Israel - are
roxas [__] those poor Palestinians
what happened they're throwing rocks at
you nobody gotta help me you know I'm
saying
ten people throw rocks nobody decides to
put Alvin and the drag I do they
complain about brain damage no cuz
they're solid those [__] people
they've been getting hit in the head
with rocks for 2,000 years
it's in their DNA nothing happens that
little bubble of the Pittsburgh steel
all these people are dying and [__]
jumping off bridges these people been
throwing rocks with each other and hit
each other in the head nothing happens
they just bend over throw another rock
back that's it everybody the UFC got
brain damage this guy got brick ain't
nobody I brained them look at those
people over there right next time you
want to talk that [__] think about the
people over there make ahead and head
with a rock what's less I mean I'd never
work with a rock
that's my [__] point let's do a bong
hit clear the air
[Music]
[Laughter]
you [__] start a periscope to
break your balls like I'm the Beatles
here you go leave
we just drove from San Jose that's the
worst drive in the [__] world
understand me dawg I told them I used to
I stopped doing that car oh yeah I
stopped and then they finally call
illegal is I'm telling them you have
till the plane figure them that is the
worst Drive because just when you get
home you still got two hours like what
the [__] what the [__] and then it's
open but once you get an outrider here
no matter where you are when you're
coming down lay you could be doing 90
and you know when you get that away
because it just stops it just stops
that's [__] calculator and you compute
on that you're gonna be there for 33
that's [__] they never experience
that make a left and approaching 3.2
miles could suck my dick don't get out
of the car cuz though you would have
back down there that's what people don't
realize it's not the [__] four-hour
drive it's that last hour that way
that's really becomes two hours now I
told him I said don't get the [__] up
early and get the [__] out of it
I never even after why is just go ahead
it's such a bad ride I might as well do
it and die I'm doing it at night I would
get right from the games at the car and
get still to LA at 5:00 a.m. it's a
[__] nightmare
that's why they got planes up there
that's why San Francisco do that run
three times you know I'm not doing this
again because yeah if you take the one
and take the beach that's if you got
your girl you got time I think I thought
it was only not time for this [__] it's
the yeah
oh [__]
it's nice and fresh these are the last
of the stock right now we're working
illegally but you know what we don't
give a [__]
done that's it just like that like a
[__] communion cookie you don't buy
this Jesus's soul that's the same way
you treat these [__] things okay look
at Paulie look at this [__] you gotta
crack it open and suck like a little
[__] dead cleveland like when it's
[__] 40s she sucks a thousand dicks
well huh BAM just like that [__]
listen nobody gets their feelings hurt
here we go we're going deep tonight how
many stars we eating Lee we got about
ten [__] when I got stars on the
verge of getting moldy they're like a
day away from getting moldy those good
ones you know our friend Berg smoked
those days he ate the mushrooms after
night he was in the bathroom on those
mushrooms that's we have to call him
back to the airport Berg you know I love
you [__]
you're a soldier for taking those
mushrooms of debt times by you if I
should linger oh [__] staring at the
ring around your finger here we go oh
[__] I have only come seeking knowledge
things they would not teach me of in
college [__] tremendous he was
dropping every [__] death honorarium
shining band of gold hey here's a champ
I'll be wrapped around your finger ego
I'll be wrapped around your bead stay go
pam pam pam pam are you [__] nuts or
what you got some H this is the night to
do it little police little synchronicity
switch it up to a little shot day and
you forget about yo D and [__] feast
like a soldier by the time the met medic
get there you're purple and your eyes
are blinking like a [__] neon light
if you're gonna go that's the way to go
I love it anyway don't forget Austin
Houston Dallas surrounding areas I ain't
traveling that muster [__] but I am
going to [__] Austin the 18th and up
listen the party starts to [__] pop
the dose understand me that [__]
toenail gumbo and the [__] is shrimp and
crab salad that's how it goes to me then
the boy some you slip it yourself Bobby
and Kristen will swing over the Chuy's
one of the days they had to do two
thousand push-ups
want to talk to me my some I don't want
to talk to you I leave me the [__] alone
all right every time you show up it cost
me a dollar fifty anyway like I was
saying up being Austin down there
rocking it with you [__] then the
following week over in hip hop array
Charlotte oh [__]
are they in the playoffs issue
[Music]
what the [__] is going on anyway
well he was quick ready to do another
bun handle we're gonna sit there like a
[__] book the law let's do another
bun at least we only like [__]
gentleman right wait some gummies it's
time for some [__] stars
[Music]
when you find your servant is your
master oh you'd be wrapped around my
finger tingly there you go oh [__] look
got any stuff to the table that's how
you know you got danger you replace the
mold it's coming this will get your
bronchitis ticking you know what eat it
with a cookie
[Music]
remember when using TNC products you got
a [__] drink water hydrate the [__]
to live in the kidney me I'm one of dr.
Amy on Wednesday little acupuncture
clean out the [__] bladder well
that's wallet THC sits and it becomes
like a [__] gummy bat she sticks to
needles that [__] before I leave
that Pete and you can see the Pete come
out in the air and just float like
because the [__] gumminess from the
[__] THC and your gallbladder
whatever I don't know the whole tunnel
eyelid goes there what am i Chinese I
don't know nothing I'm saying anyway
you know I love you [__]
youtube.com slash c / Joey dis
remember what happened last year is a
funk it's what happened this year that
matters it's what's gonna happen this
year that matters so the rest is up to
you [__] we could just walk you
to the [__] to the faucet it's up to
you whether you want to drink the water
you gonna sit there to stab me like a
[__] you know
anyway we got the Agostino here we're
gonna talk about setting goals for
comics and we'll get this straightened
out tonight the [__] and that's it we'll
be in for a little while
youtube.com / c / Joey D is the place to
be [__] the Churchill what's
happened now coming at you I don't want
to hear no [__] [__] tonight you
gotta start the year off tough as [__]
don't be surprised if we do a [__]
anthem rent
cuz it's over we got to start the year
off tough the Koreans are about to press
the button and you're [__] at
Starbucks look at a MV MTM watch
whatever the [__] it is anyway
youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz let's
get this party started right let's get
some [__] chit chat out and let's get
the New Year let's get you to work
tomorrow tip-top Magoo stay black uncle
Joey